[Music]
the ceo
of goldman sachs
will perform at lollapalooza as a dj oh
i heard about this
what's what's his name
david solomon is he really old yeah he
looks old is lollapalooza that whack now
yeah oh well you can always buy your way
into anything do aleppas up there
that's a big deal what's his uh dj name
dj gold so he says he's dj sax dj gold
sacks dj muller gold sacks would be sick
it says he moonlights
he moonlights as an electronic dance dj
named d soul diesel that's a popper like
d and then like the sun i guess that's
pretty cool he's actually girl
like [ __ ] 60s 70 years old yeah when
you think of the ceo of goldman sachs
they've got to be over 60. dude yeah he
has such a 60 year community right there
dj goldberg average age of ceos about
that age like 60 to 70. how many ceos
have a side hustle or uh or or a passion
project that they do usually it's horse
or horn and cocaine thank you be tight
if he was a if he was just spinning
financial advice ooh or like that says
drops mixed in
[Laughter]
interest dropped that was good i
followed this bodybuilder and he started
uh showing like during the pandemic you
know how like
uh everyone started showing like their
other side or whatever this is the other
stuff i'm into
this full started showing as [ __ ] dj
[ __ ] i don't want to see this [ __ ] i
don't see you [ __ ] lift weights and
it was just so weird to see him like
[ __ ] was he got it
i don't know i was watching on silent
but i was like i don't even want to see
this [ __ ] i wonder if that's how they
feel like when they see you lifting
weights they're like i followed you to
be a clown
what are you doing here [ __ ] six
years ago
it's actually the other way around
fitness i told you nikki nikki was at
the poker table this guy's like man i
love bar kwon how how much does kenny
lift and what's he do every day
because he's such a good comedian
what's his regiment like i got his
lifting regiments like comedy regiments
i think i think i think bart actually
met
the main thing he always wanted which
was being recognized as a full-on
bodybuilder when stephen graham invited
him oh yeah
dude that was good by the way the title
was so good he's like bodybuilder this
is a [ __ ] idiot who spent too much
money in these wrecks now and i'm like
jesus i like first of all i know bird
he's not this wrecked what the [ __ ] is
going on but he is an idiot he's good at
titles and then half of the comments are
jk fans going bart finally gets his wish
of being a bodybuilder
which is the best because that's even
troll right there yeah
and and graham stefan didn't even know
about youtube and jk even with the
fitness stuff because i saw the title go
up and i was like i texted him i'm like
hey i'm not really a bodybuilder and
then he uh cause i'm like i was like in
the fitness space on more of a power
lifter he's like cool i asked steve
green he disagrees
no he was like no but that'll get more
clicks so i'm like do whatever you got
to do that's time he just said that he's
right he's all right so he's just down
to like lie to the public for more
clicks well it's not i guess he's
adjusting he's molding his molding smash
that like button
this guy is a bodybuilder smash that
like button oh yeah you ever titled a
video [ __ ] missingly a piece of [ __ ]
come on most of my videos are just like
the song name okay my bad and then the
artist remix maybe you haven't i'm sorry
it's no it's not all dancers hate him
for this one simple trick haters hate
him at the 20-minute mark you wouldn't
believe what anthony d anthony did on
you're not going to believe the 12th
move he does
does it have too many titties
come on man are you new here that's how
you title dance videos should have known
what was the article about does he look
like a dj is there pictures dude he
looks like
honestly it looks like just old bruce
willis he's got a little white dude with
balls if you guys had another job to do
what would you guys do that would be
like
like i got 10 jobs bro no jobs oh yeah
that would be a nice job
to get i get i'd be my wife's grocer
because i feel like i'm already there
that guy's a dj
bruce willis he does look like old man
he looks like
give everyone a bad time that's like
expendables for bruce willis dj john
mcclane you know what though we can't we
can't judge him we can't judge him by
the clothes he has his goldman sachs
vibe on software dj goldsack's buffer
you we got to see the
great
though does he have a head piece like
like all the other popular djs
like a marshmallow yeah some like a
happy mouse a giant it's just a giant
bank vault
and he opens it up he's like he's doing
the combination of his whole set
that's how he dj's
let's [ __ ] go
has anybody here been to lollapalooza
and i haven't been at any music ninjas
actually performed there is that right
yeah and were you there i wasn't so why
did you say it like that because
because i'm trying to shameless plug
kindred what the [ __ ] dude
all you do is talk you just wear luna
hats all the time you [ __ ] shameless
plug dude no yeah i definitely don't
have any luna so they
they performed
uh and then you joined can just yeah
yeah that's when i joined that's like me
telling people hey get luna i mean i
haven't gotten it yet but you should
that's what he just said
i got school there wait how come you
were in there wanna make sure it was the
same thing yeah how come the leaders of
the kindred wasn't there i'm not the
leader she is oh i am oh great my first
order as leader how come you were not
lollipoos how come you weren't at such a
like a career definitely he was in china
for losers you guys want me to say hi
you're a [ __ ] loser and then you hate
women
were you just saying already no say it
everyone knows it if you're a part of jk
you're a woman hating son of a baby you
hate them all but seriously why weren't
you there though because not everybody
performs in every show
i always thought you were like that's
what the mask was for looking asian and
having a mask means you just replace
yourself pretty sure i recognize you in
the world of dance that was i don't know
dude you couldn't see me dude i'm pretty
sure that was you i was sick that week
do you know who christopher lambert is
no he played uh raiden in the mortal
kombat
oh the first ones yeah
he kind of looks like
he looks like david carradine he does
look like david carradine
what else is he in what else is he in
mortal kombat annihilation that's true
uh highlander [ __ ] yeah he was
highlighting his highlander two and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] that's what all three
weren't you a lollapalooza [ __ ] and oh
his exit from the series highlander four
well do you know who penelope cruz is of
course i do all right
are you talking about from vulva
the pedro almodovar movie which you're
i'm sure you're familiar with you know
what's a pretty cool side gig that i
think i'd i do um
i'd be a tropical fruit farmer
sounds like a full-time thing other than
pineapple what's a tropical fruit mango
mango
kiwi mangoes good
goodness
whoa that's some singapore stuff huh
[ __ ] what about coconut
this is my side job yeah kind of yeah
that's just the same passion fruit but
you don't got to like parade around as
another identity like that dj del sol or
whatever the hell his name is this is my
other idea like that's him like uh you
know you know me from this world i'm a
completely different identity and this
is this guy in this world my daddy gets
to talk but you're still anthony
you're not he's much gayer here than
than with ken just
yeah but you're not saying like that
might have been a compliment just media
can we accurately observe everyone's
gayness you tell me you tell me you're
not mr weasel pants or something yes or
weasel that's your dj no dude some okay
can i ask you this
let me ask you this honest question
it's just between us who knows this guy
edited out who knows
did you guys school these [ __ ] and
then afterwards you guys are like you
guys are [ __ ] losers
school witch [ __ ] what are you
talking about ninjas
and then you guys look to each other
you're like dude
they're like yeah oh yeah if we dance
with two left feet i guess we do what
kid just does like oh that's our insults
it's like little rascals level things to
say just be honest ryan it's okay we're
friends now we're we're adults now just
get them find the answers to this and
more on the kendra's podcast oh what
does that mean oh yeah you guys were on
the on their podcast that was cool you
guys talked about that yeah we did a
whole episode afterwards we talked about
everything when you
when you beat them afterwards did
someone say you got served that's that's
a good question which we did no man the
movies are so lies they say the rec
centers are so much [ __ ] overhead
it's impossible yeah we did say things
like sunny sold us out
how many rec centers do you guys have we
closed them i mean like that's not a
wreck oh you didn't save the rec center
yeah no why do i feel like we keep
talking about me closing the studios on
these videos well why do you keep going
to the studios why did you call me a
loser why do you keep closing stop
closing your studios dude you got to
save the rec center what are you
addicted to [ __ ]
hey dude honestly and
i really mean this and i love you like a
brother but can you stop taking else for
like literally two days we have an image
to uphold stop taking them start buying
else
i don't want residual loserness to
[ __ ] infect this that's my brand i
know
we want a good brand association i just
wanna
[Laughter]
during this we usually try to blame the
tricks but we don't know how yet
so don't blame the chicks blame the nick
look at how [ __ ] hurt he is this is
toxic environment for him i don't want
him to be so interesting i don't like i
don't like when my dads are all fighting
in front of me okay yeah daddy luna the
11 15 mark is where you check in with
nick's mental health how are you doing
you all right i'm upset dude i don't
like this environment it's ratchet to be
honest today is [ __ ] ratchet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you